tonight Supreme Court justices are
weighing arguments about gerrymandering
the practice of shaping political voting
districts for partisan gain the specific
case involves a rural area in Maryland
this time a traditionally blue state
where Republicans are positioned to gain
the correspondent of mackelway tells us
it has implications all over the country
the levels
roscoe Bartlett is unusual he is a
Republican in Maryland who won
re-election in this blue states sixth
congressional district for twenty years
until then Governor Martin O'Malley a
Democrat and the state's Democratic
General Assembly decided he must go they
reshaped his district quote it was my
intent to create a district where the
people would be more likely to elect a
Democrat than a Republican O'Malley
openly admitted in a recent deposition
it worked
in 2010 roscoe Bartlett won by 28 points
in 2012 after the gerrymander he lost by
21 points it is fundamentally counter
democratic the High Court heard
arguments today in Maryland's case
plaintiffs have a novel argument that
the gerrymander violated not Fourteenth
Amendment equal protection rights but
First Amendment free speech rights in
effect punishing voters for supporting
the Republican if ever there were a
violation of the First Amendment in this
context it's this the justices appeared
to be swayed that Maryland Democrats
were overly influenced by politics and
carving out the six district justice
Elena Kagan noting how much more
evidence of partisan intent could we
need Chief Justice Roberts adding part
of the objection to the way it was
redrawn is that it doesn't seem to have
any internal logic but they struggled to
unite behind what Justice Sonia
Sotomayor called a manageable standard
to define extreme gerrymandering the
courts ultimately going to decide number
one is this an issue that we as a court
can decide and resolve or is it
something best left to the political
branches the court may be hesitant to
act because in roughly two-thirds of the
states redistricting is the direct
responsibility of state legislatures
they
our duly-elected bodies this is the
second gerrymander case the court has
heard this term the first involved a
Republican redrawing of districts in
Wisconsin by hearing appeals from both
parties
Justice Kennedy may be looming large
again as a potential swing vote in the
closely divided court right Doug thank
you